[Music]
after a year of dating it's the end of
Halsey nge Z's relationships the singer
announced their split on Instagram but
interestingly less than a week before
the announcement ET sat down with gez to
promote his upcoming endless summer tour
and he wasn't shy about praising Halsey
personally and professionally
how are things going really good yeah
yeah we actually got some time away
about a week ago we in rare for the both
of us to be able to like we went to the
mountains where there's no cell phone
service and stayed in a cabin and just
chill our schedule is just as busy as
mine so that when they overlap and we
get time off it's like she's managed
yeah you know I think watching her at
the Women's March this year as a woman
myself was one of the highlights of my
year so far hopefully remind me this is
the beginning it is not the finale and
that's why we're here and that's why we
rally
she's whip-smart she is just so
musically genius are you ever in all of
her all the time she's brilliant yeah
she's really brilliant she's an amazing
person she's so intelligent so
insightful and so
you know just understanding you know
she's a brilliant human I think it would
be such a natural fit to see the two of
you link up for a joint record is that
something you've ever had a conversation
about yeah I think we could do that
pretty easily we were actually in the
sea it was just other night we did a
couple records and you know we motivate
each other and we both like we're fans
of each other's music and we have a
similar kind of perspective
aesthetically on creating music so we
play off of each other well they say
mixing business with pleasure is tough
is that the case for you guys how do you
balance that mm-hmm I mean mixing
business and pleasure and charts and
state and all that that's like um
but at the end of the day this is about
having integrity for each other the
right way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]